thank you
okay
here in your body reach your body Center
and give me your sense
same thing here
same thing give it to me okay
and already
relationship okay
give it to your legs
foreign
[Music]
you touch my Center through your elbow
knock knock this is not possible okay
Center
good
answer give me your Center oh good
give it again
okay and keep touching mine
good
you know that's my arms
same thing
boom
okay
[Music]
give it release touch mine
release it's mine
foreign
good
[Music]
much better just like that we keep going
center it's dry dry there you go
connection touch my Center
good
again touch my Center yield
again connection up
touch my Center
good
[Music]
good release surrender
keep
ing away from me